ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
วันนี้มีนักเรียนกี่คนคะผู้หญิงวันนี้มี
นักเรียน 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
11 คนค่ะนักเรียน 11 คนนะคะแล้ววันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสค่ะวันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7 ค่ะวันที่ 7
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายนปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565  2566
[เพลง]
เมื่อปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลาบ่ายโมง
38 นาทีค่ะ
13:30 น 8 นาทีนนะคะไทยค่ะครูหญิงนัก
เรียนมามาๆรบ 11 คนไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนมาครบ 11 คน
เย้วรรคนักเรียนอยากจะมาดูผักค่ะครูเอ๋
ดูผักซ้ายคลิป 2 คลิปที่แล้วมีผักอย่า
ก็จะดูผักอีกนะคะเอาใครค่ะได้จากไปค่ะผัก
เป็นยังไงนะ
อ่า
นี่ค่ะ
โห
โอเคครูเห็นแล้วใช่ไหมคะเห็นค่ะหมอผักใน
รูปชื่ออะไรคะ
ตะไคร้
ตะไคร้ค่ะครูเอ๋กินไหมคะครูเอ๋กินตะไคร้
ผู้หญิงกินตะไคร้ไหมคะ
ยินฮะไม่กินคู๋
ชอบกินตะไคร้โฮ้ครูเอ๋เอ๋แล้วครูเอ๋กิน
ตรงไหนคะ
กินทั้งหมด
ทั้งหมดได้ยินได้กินได้
ครูเอ๋เก่งมากค่ะผู้หญิงคู๋เอาไปต้มอา
จะ
ใช้ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะมีหม้อ
มีหม้อมีน้ำเอาตะไคร้ใส่
ไปเปิดไฟมีไฟ
อันนี้ต้ม
ต้มแล้วก็น้ำตะไคร้
ดื่มอ๋ออ๋อครูเอ๋ดื่มน้ำตะไคร้ใช่ค่ะก็
ใช้ตรงนี้
ครูเอ๋เอามา
ซอยซอยเล็กๆ
อันนี้ใหญ่ไม่ได้เล็กๆอันนี้ไม่ซอยใช่ไหม
ในรูปไม่อยู่ซอยในรูปหั่นซอย
แล้วก็กินโอเค
โอ้ยอร่อยค่ะนะคะกูเองกินตะไคร้คู่หญิง
กินตะไคร้ไหมคะไม่กินค่ะไม่กินต้มราคาต้ม
แล้วดื่มน้ำกินค่ะอ๋อดื่มน้ำตะไคร้แต่ไม่
กิน
ไม่กินแต่ครูเอกกินชอบใช่ไหมคะครู a ซ่อม
ชอบกินตะไคร้ค่ะโอเคอ่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ผัดในรูปชื่ออะไรคะ
ขิงค่ะขิงครูเอ๋เอ๋กินขิงไหมคะกินค่ะนี้
มีคอกไหมคะชอบค่ะผู้หญิงกินขิงไหมคะกิน
ค่ะชอบไหมคะ
นี่เฉยเฉยๆครูเอ๋ชอบมากอ๋อโอเคครอบมาก
ตะไคร้ตะไคร้ก็ชอบมากค่ะขิงชอบมากค่ะ
โอเคค่ะ
ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋เหมือนกันค่ะตอ
รี่ Live ผักในรูปชื่ออะไรคะข่าค่ะค่ะทาง
อ๋ออ๋อค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋กินขาไหมคะรู้เหยินขาด
แต่ถ้า
ชอบไหมคะชอบมาก
โมโหมาก
ๆ
ผู้หญิงกินข่าวไหมคะกินค่ะครูผู้หญิงชอบ
ข่าวไหมคะเฉยเฉยๆขอคุยชอบ
มากๆครูเอ๋คะอัดตรงนี้ของขาดเราเรียกอะไร
คะเหงาค่ะ
เราค่ะแล้วตรงนี้นะคะที่มันต้นยาวต้น
ต้นคากินได้มั้ยคะกินไหมคะ R
นิ่มกินได้แข็งๆกินไม่ได้
สีชมพู
กลิ่นได้อย่างนี้เหรอคะสีชมพูทีน่ะแบบนี้
แล้วคะสีคะเดี๋ยวไม่ได้
แข็งไม่กินนิ่มๆกินได้ค่ะแม่โอเคขัดตอบดี
เหรอคะกินดีแข็งแรงโทรนักเรียนกินค่ะแข็ง
แรงขา
มันต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋ผัดอะนี้
ชื่ออะไรคะต้นหอมค่ะนี้ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินต้น
หอมไหมคะรู้เหมือนต้นหอมครูข้อ
ผู้หญิงกินต้นหอมไหมคะ
ไม่กิน
ผู้หญิงไม่กิน
ไม่กินครูเอ๋เอ๋กินเริ่มต้นหอม Pro  S
ชอบไหมคะชอบต้นหอมมากโป๊ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋กิน
ต้นหอมกินที่ใบอธิบายใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
แล้วตรงนี้เรียกอะไรคะต้นค่ะครูเอ๋กินใบ
กินต้นค่ะ 2 อย่างรากไม่กินไม่ตอบว่าราด
จินะราชออกไม่กินไม่กินรากมากค่ะนี้ไม่
ใบกินต้นกิน
นะครูหญิงมั้ยกินคู่เอกกินใบต้นหอมกินต้น
ต้นหอมไม่กินรากต้นหอมค่ะ
ตัดต่อไปค่ะคุณครูเอ๋พันธุ์ต่อไปเป็นอะไร
คะ
ครูเอ๋ผัดในรูปเรียกว่าอะไรคะขอมใหญ่นี้
อันนี้ต้นหอมต้นหอม
ของใหญ่เหมือนกันไหมคะ
ไม่เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนต้นหอมเล็กๆชนิด
เล็กๆพร้อมใหญ่ๆห*ครูเอ๋กินหอมใหญ่ไหมคะ
กินค่ะน้องชอบไหมคะชอบมากค่ะโห
ชอบมากๆๆ
รอยผู้หญิงกินหอมใหญ่ไหมคะ
กินค่ะ
ถ้าชอบไหมคะ
เฉยๆเฉยๆตัวเองศพของใหญ่ครูเอ๋สีส้มสีส้ม
เนี่ยท้องหอมใหญ่เรียกว่าอะไรคะเปลือกค่ะ
แล้วสีขาวตรงนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเนื้อค่ะ
นี้นะของใหญ่กิน
ค่ะกินตรงไหนกินเนื้อไม่กินเปลือกขอสีส้ม
ไม่กิน
[เพลง]
ครูหญิง
เอาไม่รู้ตัวเองได้
พูดดีๆใจเย็นๆ
ผู้หญิงให้กูเอกกินเปลือกไม่กิน
ไม่รู้อิอิ
อ่านครูเอ๋ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋กูแอบชอบผักแก่
ผัดต่อไปเรียกว่าอะไรคะรูปนี้หอมแดง
หอมแดงกับหอมใหญ่
เหมือนกันไหมคะไม่เหมือนกัน
แม่ของแดงเล็กๆหอมใหญ่ใหญ่ๆเอาพร้อมต้น
หอมต้นหอม
ต้นหอมแดงเหมือนกัน
เอา
เหมือนกันต้นหอมเป็นต้นใช่ไหมคะพอต้นหอม
นานๆสีขาวเปลี่ยนเป็นหอมแดงตรงนี้หรอคะ
ใครค่ะอ๋ออ๋อนานๆแล้วก็อ่ะเปลี่ยนหอมแดง
ถ้าๆ
ครูเอ๋กินหอมแดงไหมคะกินค่ะอยากกินทุกข้อ
ไหมคะชอบมาก
หัวเข้าใจ
ครึ้มไม่กินเปลือก
นรกแซวค่ะรู้แล้วครูเอ๋เนี่ยอันนี้เนอะ
เนี่ยตรงนี้นะครับเหลือบไม่กินอีเลอ้ะกิน
ครูเอ๋กินหอมแดงไหมคะไม่กิน
จบถามไม่ได้
ทำไมกินทำมันผู้หญิงจมูกไม่โอเคค่ะกินหอม
แดงตัว a ชอบค่ะชอบกินหอมแดง
ก็รู้เอง
ในในถ้วยมีหอมแดงเท่าไร
ในถ้วยถ้วยนะคะมีค่ะ
2  3  4  5  6
7 มี 8 ข้างล่างไหมคะไม่มีค่ะไม่มีไม่มี
ไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีข้างล่างนะไม่เห็นไอ้ที่
เห็นเนี่ย
7 ผ้าค่ะ 730
[เพลง]
เธอเก่งมากที่
โอเคอาทิตย์
ใส่เวลาทำอาหาร
ทำอาหารใส่โอเคค่ะอะผัดต่อไปค่ะรู๋อะไรคะ
กระเทียม
โหกระเทียมครูเอ๋กินกระเทียมไหมคะกินค่ะ
ก็ชอบไหมคะชอบมาก
ถึงนี้
กินคุยฮะคู่เอกกินที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะกิน
กระเทียมที่อยู่ใน 3 ไปค่ะ
ครูเอ๋หยิบกระเทียมใส่ปาก
แบบนี้เหรอคะครูเอ๋ใช่ค่ะ
ทำไมกูหญิงกินกระเทียมไหมอ่ะถ้าไม่กิน
ไม่ชอบใช้ซองใส่ค่ะกินไม่ชอบไม่สอบ E  Men
of เม้นท์ล่ะคะ Man ค่ะหอมหอมแม่แนนขอ
เหม็นค่าหน่อครูหญิงเหม็นครูเอ๋หอมนัก
เรียนกินกระเทียมมั้ย
นักเรียนคิดกระเทียมเหม็นหรือ
หมอมคู๋นักเรียนนักเรียนยกมือ
ว่าไม่เหม็น
[เพลง]
รัตน์นักเรียน
รักมวลใช่ให้ให้แม่หนูถ้า
ผอมแบดดี้ใช่ไหมกระเทียมกินแล้วแข็งแรง
ดีไม่ดีค่ะดี่
[เพลง]
ดีกว่าไหมคะกินค่ะภาพไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะ
ซ่อมก็นิดหน่อยชอบ
ก็มาโอเค
ครูเอ๋
อ่ะเปลือกแตงกวากินได้ไหมคะกินได้ค่ะน้อ
ทั้งหมดกินได้กินได้คู่หญิงกินเปลือกแตง
กวาไหมคะกินค่ะค่ะครูหญิงกินเปลือกแตงกวา
ค่ะ
มีอะไรอีกผัดต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
ห*หัดในรูป
ชื่อไอ้คะ
เดี๋ยวค่ะ
เป็นผักคนไทยนะผักของผัดไทยอ่ะชื่อฟัก
เขียว
พี่เก๋ฝากเขียวเหมือนแตงกวาไหมคะไม่
เหมือนค่ะไม่เหมือนนะแตงกวาแตงกวาหยิบมา
กัดแล้วก็เคี้ยวกลืน
โอเคอ้าวฟักเขียวล่ะคะป๋าเขียวเอามากัด
ตอบไม่ได้ต้องต้มค่ะต้องมีหม้อ
และมีหม้อ
หม้อ
ก่อนมีไฟ
แล้วก็ทันหันๆสักเขียวใส่ลงไปต้ม
แล้วกิน
นี่
นี่ค่ะกูอาจจะได้หิวกูเย้อ่า
คะอันนี้นะคะปั๊บเขียวที่ครูเอ๋บอกเอาไป
ต้ม
หิวข้าว
ครูเอ๋กินฟักเขียวไหมคะผู้เห*๊ยกินฟัก
เขียวค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะกูเอชอบฟัดเขียวค่ะหนู
มาผู้หญิงกินฟักเขียวไหมคะกินค่ะผู้หญิง
ชอบฟักเขียวไหมคะพ่อชอบค่ะ
สอบนักเรียน
รู้จักไหม
เรียนรู้จักไหมนักเรียนทำหน้า
อะไรใช่ค่ะค่ะแต่เหมือนคู่เอ๋บอกเขาไปต้ม
เอาไปต้มต่อรอยอร่อยค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋
เอ๋
มี
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ผัดในรูปมะละกอ
มะละกอดิบหนอมาลากอค่ะมะละกอเปลือกใช่ไหม
คะสีเปลือกสีอะไรคะสีเขียวค่ะเนื้อ
เนื้อสีขาว
แล้วตรงนี้
พูดเอ๋คุยอะไรก่อนไหมคะโอเคมั้ย
กูเอ๋แย่แล้วสำลัก
น้ำลายเข้าดีใจอยู่เพจได้ไหมคะ
โอเคค่ะได้ค่ะโอเคค่ะตรงนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
คะครูเอ๋เมล็ดค่ะเลสเนาะครูเอ๋กินมะละกอ
ไหมคะกินค่ะปิดภาษาอังกฤษนะคะชอบไหมครับ
ชอบมากค่ะโอ้วคะครูหญิงกินมะละกอไหมคะกิน
ค่ะมอบไหมคะ
ชอบมากค่ะ
สองคนชอบกินมะละกอ
เอกทรายอัดต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
ในรูปชื่ออะไรคะตา
มีหลายชื่อเนาะมีหลายชื่อคนไทยพูดไชเท้า
นะ
ไชเท้าภาษา
จีนใช่มะกับภาษาไทย
ไชเท้าบางคนพูดหัวผักกาดออแต่เหมือนกัน
ตายชื่อไชเท้าชื่อหัวผักกาดโอเค a พูด
ไชเท้า
พูดอะไรครูหญิงจะใช้เถาค่ะ
โอเคเราสองคนเรียกว่าไชเท้านะคะใส่ค่ะครู
เอ๋เอ๋กินใช้ทวไหมคะรู้เหมือนใช้เท่าค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะครูเอ๋ชอบใช้ทวรู้หญิงกินใช้เทา
ไหมคะกินค่ะกินผู้หญิงชอบใช้เทาไหมคะ
ชอบชอบฮะชอบ
ชอบ
ชอบแต่
ไม่มาก
ชอบโอเค
สอบแต่ไม่มากนะคะพอพี่เอ๋
มาก
โหครูแอร์คะใช้เท้าตรงนี้เราเรียกอะไรคะ
หัวค่ะแล้วแล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะคะอาการค่ะ
กินได้ไหมคะอันนี้ใบอะนี้อันนี้
เหมือนได้ที่หรอแต่คนไม่กินอ๋ออ๋อกินได้
แต่ไม่กินอะไรกินได้อร่อยด้วยอ๋อเห็นไหม
คุยก็เลยถามไงว่าปรื๊ดหัวหอมกินไหม
เปลือกหัวหอมไม่กิน
กูเอ๋ว่ะ
ไม่ต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
หาดในรูปชื่ออะไรคะฟักทองฟักทองอันนี้
เผือกฟักทองที่ไทยอ่ะของไทยสีอะไรคะสี
เขียวไหมสีเขียวเนาะเออ
มาหาแล้วเนื้อฟักทองถ้าเนื้อฟักทองสี
เหลืองค่ะแล้วตรงนี้เรียกอะไรคะเมล็ดค่ะ
เหลือดกินได้ไหมครับครูเอ๋
คนก็กิน in ได้กินได้แต่บางคนไม่เอาต้อง
บอกเอาเปลือกทิ้งราคาป่ารู๋แล้วอ๋อเห็น
ไหมแล้วเม็ด
เม็ดฟักทองกินได้ไหมคะออถ้าอันนี้ไม่กิน
แบบถ้าเอาเอามาแล้วก็ไปทำกินได้
หืออร่อยอร่อยๆอ้ะรู๋กินฟักทองไหมคะกิน
ค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบมากงู
[เพลง]
มีผู้หญิงกินฟักทองไหมคะกินค่ะชอบฟักทอง
ไหมคะ
ชอบค่ะ
มากชอบอีกชอบ
ไม่มากใช่ไหมไม่มามากพอมากโหดีค่ะอ่าอ่ะ
ตัดต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋
ผัดในรูปชื่ออะไรคะเห็ดเข็มทองครูเอ๋เอ๋
กินเห็ดเข็มทองไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบโอเคอ๋อชอบโอเคชอบชอบแบม
เค้านี้
ไม่ใช่ชอบมากไม่ใช่ชอบมากไม่กินโอเคกินฮะ
โอเค
ผู้หญิงชอบกินไหมกินค่ากินชอบไหมคะ
ชอบมาก
ขับมากเหรอคะสอบบาท
ไม่กินโอเคกินโอเคผู้หญิงไปกับครูเอ๋ครู
เอ๋ให้ครูหญิงกิน
กูเองกินได้ชอบแต่ไม่ได้ชอบมากๆนะสามก็
คือไม่กินก็โอเคไม่เป็นไรแต่ฟักทองกูเอง
เอานะออกฟังทองครูเอกชอบมาก
มากค่ะชอบมากค่ะเอาไม่ใช่ชอบมากชอบผัด
เห็นไหมภาคต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋เห็ดเหมือนกัน
ถ้า
เห็ดอะไรนะคะในรูปเห็ดขอมน้องเห็ดหอมครู
เอ๋กินเห็ดหอมไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบมากเอ้า
ชอบเห็ดเห็ดเข็มทองชอบซอนิเห็ดเข็มทอง
ชอบหนอ
เข็มทองเข็มทองเห็ดเข็มทองชอบเห็ดหอม
อ๋อ
พระเอกชอบเห็ดหอมเวลานักเรียนได้ยินชอบ
แปลว่าโอเคชอบค่ะชอบ
มากนะคะใช่
ชอบค่ะอ่ากินเห็ดหอมไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบเห็ดหอมไหมคะถ้าไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชินยัง
ไม่ต้องกิน
กินไงแต่ไม่ชอบเม้นข้อของชื่อเห็ดของหอม
ไอ๋
หอมครูหญิงแมนโอเคดีเอามาเอามาให้ให้ให้
ครูเอ๋ค่ะครูผู้หญิงมี
มีค่ะมีอีกนะคะค่ะโอ้เห็ดอะไรคะในรูปเห็ด
หูหนู
ครูเอ๋เอ๋กินเห็ดหูหนูไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะ
ชอบโมโหมากกว่าเห็ดหอมไพ่ชอบ
I
Wait ท่อบกินเห็ดหูหนูผู้หญิงกินเห็ดหู
หนู
เห็ดหูหนูดำอ๋อ
หนูอย่าล่ะคะครูเอ๋ดำใช่ไหมค่ะ
ใช่มั้ยเห็ดหูหนูค่ะดำกินเห็ดหูหนูดำไหม
คะกินค่ะกินชอบไหมคะข้อชอบค่ะ
ไม่แบ่งของครูหญิง
ไม่ได้อีกไหมเย้ค่ะ
ผัดในรูปชื่ออะไรคะเห็ดคู่หูหนูขาว
เหมือนกันซื่อบื้อก็เหมือนกันอ่ะเห็ดหู
หนูน่ะหูหนูดำ
หูหนูขาวอ๋อนี่สีอะไรคะสีขาวอ่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋
กินเห็ดหูหนูขาวไหมคะกินค่ะ
ชอบไหมคะชอบมาก
ตายแล้วครูผู้หญิงกินเห็ดหูหนูขาวไหมคะ
กินค่ะชอบไหมคะชอบมาก
อะไม่ได้ยินเสียงเขาหายแล้วชอบมากมา
ชอบมากเลยอ่ะใจค่ะของครูหญิง
เฮ้ยไม่เป็นไรซื้อมากๆอ่าทรายสายๆอ่ะครู
เอ๋เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงเช่นแป๊บนึงอ่ะโอเคค่ะ
อ้าแต่ว่าหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะเวลาแล้ว
หรือว่ายัง
เราเริ่มเท่าไหร่ 36  46 ทั้งหมดเวลาแล้ว
ถูกค่ะครูเอ๋วันนี้ทรายๆก็นักเรียนรู้จัก
ผักมากๆครูชอบผักทั้งหมดมั๊ยค่ะครูเอ๋กิน
ผัดทั้งหมดมีชอบชอบมากชอบมากไม่เท่ากัน
ค่ะ
นักเรียนชอบอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอกเราได้นะคะ
วีดีโอนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย